now and everyone is very concerned with
their appearance there
like people always say to me Caroline
your face is so full what kind of filler
do you use is it Restylane or Juvederm
I'm like fudge
Caroline Ray is a comedic genius from
stand up to Sabrina the Teenage Witch
she has done it all in Hollywood and
this weekend she'll be performing at
Jimmy Kimmel's Comedy Club welcome to
the show Caroline Ray I am overwhelmed
everyone here is first of all so
attractive and I want to be on I want to
go to all the shows sticks it's crazy
sticks I was in a movie with sticks you
were yes and they were my first album
and Brian Adams played at my college did
he really what movie were you in with
sticks I'm trying to remember it was
with Hilary Duff and uh the perfect man
no kidding yeah they didn't because
um Mike O'Malley was obsessed with
sticks and there was a whole thing and
then they came on and did a piece what
do people recognize you most work when
people see you oh gosh I don't know I
get called witch every day and I'm
hoping that's not just for men
I've been called a witch in every
language every country from Sabrina the
Teenage way yes that is it that is that
is it I answered and Hilda I just do
because you're so used to it yeah I am
do people ever mistake you for another
celebrity oh this is hilarious uh this
woman came up to me and she was oh no
first of all I know this when they come
up to me and go your work is so
important I I always go no hold on I'm
not Catherine O'Hara
um because that's the important one and
then uh yeah
um this woman was like oh my God I love
you and we were going to sit down and I
said and she said and I've seen all your
specials and I said oh that's so nice
and you're so funny I said that's so
kind of you and then in French she said
I need two tickets for Amy Schumer and I
was like uh and I felt so bad I didn't
want to tell her it wasn't Amy Schumer
because I didn't want to embarrass her
and then she came up to me it's like
that is so embarrassing why didn't you
tell me I was like oh you can't win you
can't win it's Joey and cartilage based
you know what I mean like when I go to
Scotland everyone's like oh people say
that I look just like you I'm like you
do look like me you also look like a
snowman and a baby you know what I mean
anybody that's like cheeky my face is
gonna hurt I'm just laughing at you
you're the awesome cheeky you're you're
bone-based I am cold I'm cartilage based
I'm very bony like the wind blows and
I'm like can move you know you doing
Jimmy Kimmel's Comedy Club I am uh let's
talk about late night talk show hosts
because I've heard something is this
true the G were you on Magic Johnson's
very last show yes I was I I don't feel
responsible for having killed the show
no he had a talk show for him I was the
last one and let me tell you I was I
I was being interviewed by him and I was
a little like Starstruck is Magic
Johnson yeah because he had the biggest
feet I've ever seen in my entire life
and I get and I was like like I'm sure
during the interview I was like it must
be a size like 18. are you sure it's the
biggest butt I've ever seen I was like
yeah I I killed him I killed his truck
oh wow a nine and a half right here is
pretty impossible
nine and a half
yes I I I've killed lots of people to
talk to this don't kill this one because
this guy's on fire no this show is on
fire I think it's our six year or seven
year anniversary coming up this month
it's so okay so explain to people that
you and I have met before because we did
a radio show yeah I still do it but in
1997 I just started I was a producer and
one of the hosts they were out for the
day so I got to step in yeah you got a
total radio voice thank you face no stop
uh I was so I was co-hosting the day and
you were our guest and I'll never forget
I was so nervous and I asked you a
question and I Paul was thinking he
wouldn't answer and you responded and
you were funny and so you were my first
ever celebrity guest that I interviewed
and the first celebrity that asked the
question see I career launched and
career killed I run the full gamut you
don't know which one you're gonna get
from me we came full so coming up this
year yes from the concerts yeah Taylor
Swift I know and Beyonce you can only go
to one which do you choose okay first of
all I never know that I'm pronouncing
her name correctly it's Beyonce Beyonce
because I always say Beyonce okay
so um Beyonce many years ago I was
presenting an award with um can't
remember because I don't remember
anything and um good story uh smaller
country act small okay I got nothing
okay and and now I'm not gonna say what
it is because they'll be offended that I
said it anyway not small like in Fame
small and small sure okay he was married
to Renee zellberg
no no no okay you don't know okay using
all my time to play again anyway okay
we're ready
okay and anyway and Beyonce Beyonce came
over to me and said Miss Caroline I love
Sabrina so much oh and she was the most
beautiful sweetest girl and I said well
you know you have to come in the show
sometimes she's like oh would you really
let us come on the show sometime anyway
she was not able to because but she was
asked a lot of times and Taylor Swift I
literally
have a good story very quickly okay we
have time for the quick story no yeah my
daughter loves Taylor Swift she was in
second grade she was going to be a guest
on Kelly and Ryan and Michael Gelman and
Laurie gellman are my beloved friends
they were like bring Ava to the show
Taylor Swift is going to be on so I'm
like sitting in the guest in you know in
the green room with my daughter
and then they said I said to her listen
she's just a beautiful talented girl but
she's a regular human being so don't go
crazy she's just like say hello to her
don't freak out on her okay
so she comes in the room and she walks
over to Ava and she goes hi she someone
told me a lot of time she goes hi Ava
she goes your mother is so funny and Ava
goes thank you and I go
you know who I am
I love your family I was so humiliating
I love it we can't get enough of you but
we can see you Caroline performing at
Jimmy Kimmel's comedy club tonight and
Sunday thank you so much that doesn't it
look like I know all the words to Jesus
Take the Wheel in that picture
Kenny Chesney with the country